[Music]
hi robin how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
thank you for taking my call my question
today is my husband and i own a home
and we're looking to we're hoping to
move soon but we also have some debt um
so we're just trying to figure out the
best next steps um
for
for ourselves
okay why are you moving
um we need more space we have a two
bedroom and we have an 18 month old spot
and we would like to try for another
baby uh soon
we would like to have a three bedroom
house and i also work from home so we do
need like some type of office space or
area okay how much data have you got not
counting your house
not counting the house i would say
70 50 in
student loans and um i'm sorry 55 in
student loans at 15 and credit cards
okay
and um
what's your household income
95 000. good for you okay what do you
guys do for a living
um i am a financial analyst and my
husband works in auto manufacturing okay
all right well your goal
of moving up in-house to have you know a
little more room for your family is a
great goal
and it's a reasonable goal
i think we can agree it is a want
and not a need
um okay i would say like we could get to
a need is shelter
you have shelter
you have one baby and a two-bedroom
house
everything's okay today
but it'd be nice to move up it'd be nice
to move up i'm not saying you can't do a
one i spend money on once i'm okay with
that but we need to classify it where it
really is now the number one
key to building wealth the number one
wealth building tool that you have is
your income and when you send it all to
sally may
it's very difficult to build wealth
and so
before you buy once
you get your
house in order
no pun intended um and uh that means you
get these debts paid off
and so if i'm you i'm rolling up my
sleeves i'm gonna work as much as i can
work i'm gonna live on nothing and i'm
gonna knock out these debts asap
and
it's probably going to take you 18
months and that's living on beans and
rice
18 months so you suggesting in the house
for now stay in the house
and get out of debt
before you spend money on luxuries which
is a move up in house is a luxury
your family is not going to die if you
don't move up in-house it would just be
a really nice thing to get to move up
in-house that means it's a luxury not a
need
yeah it would just be uncomfortable and
i guess
a lot of things to cut expenses but like
daycare is so expensive we pay
um we pay
1300 a month and daycare is more than
ours your option is to move up in house
and keep the debt and you will be stuck
in the middle class the rest of your
life because you're not dealing with
your issues
i want you to become wealthy
i need you
when you move up in house you're going
to move up in-house payment now your
budget's going to be even tighter
because sally mae also needs her own
bedroom
yeah so robin you do make a very good
point you can cut expenses
so what can we do to reduce the child
care cost got to look at it from 18
different angles where there's a will
there's a way is an old phrase and in
this case yes 1300 a month for child
care
that's a lot and it's more than your
mortgage you said so i would absolutely
be doing what dave said but finding ways
to make more money and reduce cost which
means you could take that 18 months as
dave saying with rice and beans and the
more income we add the more intensity we
add the quicker you get out of this
debt and now we can begin to think about
the future but your focus needs to be on
the now thanks robin we appreciate your
call